know when to hold them
nowhere to fold them
nowhere to walk away
no when to run deadpool yeah that's
right i can't wait to
to join the gang can't wait to give the
beast a nice little belly rub it's gonna
be great yeah i can't wait to move in
who doesn't love rich mahogany seriously
it's called the x-men i mean there are
women here right it's very sexist i know
right put the little mouth
thank you lesbian commander we have
everything we need now
thank you you don't have everything you
need you're missing black hats
1980s burglars tell the rest of the
trench coat mafia that they look better
in a trench coat than the two of you he
looks like that guy from lord of the
rings if he had gotten cancer you're the
size of gollum with worst taste in
fashion sputnik let's [ __ ] go
on delay on delay you big silver sex toy
you tamp on chewing glistening communist
[ __ ] let's go
dr phil can wait you can watch the
matthew mcconaughey lincoln commercials
later you communist [ __ ] watch your hair
on the way out sweetie it's low
clearance
yeah i didn't know miley cyrus joined
the cure huh if you bring your son back
make sure he has id
the little one looked like justin bieber
face [ __ ] miley cyrus's haircut you're
gonna leave me all alone here with
christianmingle.com
leave me all alone here with kevin sorbo
you're all you're going to leave me here
all alone with nikki sixx gonna leave me
all alone here with buster rhymes are
you gonna leave me all alone here with
henry winkler you know leave me all
alone here with hey you guys you're
gonna leave me all alone here with chris
angel mind freak you know leave me all
alone here with less angry rosie
o'donnell
sorry gina
[ __ ]
like a young kirk cameron
you're not wearing any pants where'd you
hide that
uh nowhere they say um
oh i wouldn't do that
happy lyme disease awareness day
okay thank you
oh [ __ ] you're right happy atlantis for
a set day
thanks baby
what are you gonna say to her god damn
it now you should leave with a joke you
know something tasteful but it also
alludes to her [ __ ] you might want to
leave the room
because i bet it feels huge in this hand
or stay
let's go next level with this [ __ ]
oh
easy easy
come on
surprise surprise happy friday so just
the deadpool bloopers outtakes band
material jokes that they had to pull out
of the film i'll do a new round of the
logan blu-ray giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video hands down
probably my favorite outtake from this
is her licking that star pop where did
you hide that oh you know no no nowhere
not totally up my butt just takes a big
old lick of it oh geez that's foul if
you guys didn't know she is coming back
for the sequel most of the characters
that didn't die off are coming back and
obviously we have josh brolin coming on
as cable the biggest thing about that
too he started to tease his workouts
like he's got to get those huge cable
guns but he had to sign a five picture
deal and i think that's mostly working
out because thanos won't be quite as big
a deal after both of these upcoming
avengers films but we can talk about
that when we get there let me know which
one of these outtakes from this is your
favorite and this is ryan reynolds
reacting to the movie getting banned in
china
divided by fear one man must stand alone
deadpool rated [ __ ] you you'll never see
this
no i honestly it's easy for me to wear
that as a badge of honor like we got
banned in china i hate that i wish
i i love china and i would love the
people of china to see deadpool
obviously they're really careful about
the movies they let in you can't have
certain supernatural elements you can't
do really crazy violence stuff like this
the list of things that they censor is
crazies so let me know if you live in a
part of the world that censors movies
from the united states this heavily they
won't let movies in if they're this
graphic or i should say this awesome
whole bunch of comic book stuff posting
tomorrow i have some new justice league
they talk a little bit about the new
scenes that joss whedon has been working
on for the past couple of months they'll
be shooting pretty soon so while you
wait for that to post you can click here
for brand new spider-man homecoming
footage and you can click here to
re-watch the deadpool 2 teaser trailer
thank you so much for watching let's
high five i'll see you guys tonight